[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE HAINES: First
of all, I'm actually
just curious to know how many
of you here in this audience
were either born outside
the United States,
or have a parent that was born
outside the United States?
Just to get a show of hands.
All right.
I'd say that's
almost half the room.
Interesting.
OK, so just giving you a
sense of your audience.
MARY SKAFIDAS: That's great.
JESSE HAINES: So tell us a
little bit about where you came
up with the idea for this
book, which is, again,
72 essays all about immigration,
from folks that you've heard
of and others that you haven't.
But like, why?
ANDREW TISCH: Well, I had
joined the board of the New York
Historical Society.
And one of the things we have at
the New York Historical Society
is a very nice auditorium
that we loan out
periodically to the immigration
and Naturalization Service.
So I was asked if I
would offer greetings
to 100 new immigrants
who were being
sworn in on behalf of NYHS.
I said, sure, why not?
And as I was
preparing my remarks,
I decided to talk about how my
family got here-- the family
lore of how we came to America.
And as I was sitting there
looking out on the audience,
I thought to myself,
everyone has a story.
Virtually every one
of us is an immigrant.
And with everything
that's going on--
and this was now 18 months
ago, 24 months ago--
with everything that was
going on then, I said,
why not start to tell
some of the stories?
And so I went back to the
office and talked to Mary.
And Mary and I had been
writing for several years,
writing op-eds together.
And I said to her, how would
you like to write a book?
You're not gonna make any money.
MARY SKAFIDAS: I ran away
and hid under my desk.
No.
I was very engaged, and
wanted to do this right
from when he said it.
We had a great time just
researching his family history.
And I was born here, but
I didn't speak English
till I was five years old
because my parents just spoke
Greek, and still
just speak Greek.
So it was something that was
near and dear to my heart.
And you could see, when he
came back from the ceremony,
he was energized.
It was like, we're
all immigrants.
And it shouldn't be an epiphany.
We are all immigrants.
But it takes a moment like that
for you to really realize it.
JESSE HAINES: And then what?
You've got such an amazing
collection of stories
here from everyone
from Marlo Thomas,
Nancy Pelosi, Rabbi Angela--
like just such a mix.
How did you find these people?
Were they reluctant to share?
Excited to [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW TISCH: Very few people
were reluctant to share.
As a matter of fact,
when you talk to people,
they got energized by it.
You know, many
people, after we asked
them three or four
questions, would
start to come up with things
that they hadn't thought about.
And at the end of
the discussion,
they were thanking us.
But we started out by
interviewing people.
And we realized, or at least
I came to the realization,
I can't write in
another person's voice.
So maybe I was being a
little bit lazy, but I said,
why don't you write an essay?
Write 500 to 1,500 words
about how you or your family
got here.
And then we'll do
a light edit on it.
And the stories
that we got in were
unbelievable because it
was people really pouring
their hearts out about what
America meant to them, what
their family meant to them.
It was the stories.
Each one of them tells a story.
And collecting the stories
was kind of the easy part,
because people wanted to.
It was telling people, no, we
have enough stories already,
or no, we don't need
this story or that story.
So getting people to
open up their hearts,
open up their minds,
write about it,
that was kind of the easy part.
JESSE HAINES: What
were the common themes?
I know you categorized the
stories throughout the book.
You kind of grouped them.
But tell us a little
bit about some
of the themes that emerged
as you started to look across
all these fascinating tales.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Well,
overwhelmingly there's hope.
There's hope and courage,
and that comes across.
Even though that there's
different chapters--
there is the fleers.
There's the lovers.
There is the survivors.
Even as you look
across from them,
they're leaving a place
for something better,
and it takes a tremendous
amount of courage
to be able to leave
everything you know,
even if it's not great,
and try to set up
a life in this new country.
But I think we carve the
chapters up into themes,
but really, a lot of the
stories would fit in any chapter
because I think the
common theme of hope,
and bravery, and courage come
through in almost all of them.
ANDREW TISCH: One
of the problems
we had early on was figuring out
how to divide up the chapters.
So we thought about
doing it alphabetically.
And then we realized,
well, we have
Alan Alda, and Arleen Alda,
and we have Ashok Amritraj,
and Ahmed Ahmed.
We had way too many AAs for 72,
so we couldn't do it that way.
We couldn't do it
geographically,
because you had Europe,
Africa, so you'd almost
be doing it racially,
which we didn't want to do.
We couldn't do it
chronologically
because we had people
from the Mayflower,
and people who came over--
we literally had one person
who wrote his essay on the day
that he was sworn
in as a US citizen.
And we decided to do it--
MARY SKAFIDAS: Thematically.
ANDREW TISCH: --thematically.
We had people who
were coming over here
for opportunity, people
who are coming over here
for love, people who were coming
over here fleeing something.
But I guess the common theme
was that people came over here
for opportunity, and
because they really
believed that there were
things here that they couldn't
get anywhere else in the world.
And I'll take the
example of my family, who
came from [? Dniprovska, ?]
which was in Ukraine.
And they could have just
as easily gone to Warsaw.
It probably would
have been much easier
to go to Warsaw, which had a
great Jewish community there
in 1905, and it would have
been a very safe choice.
And they would have
been wiped out.
And I would never have been
here after World War II.
Somebody in my family,
probably my great grandfather,
took a leap of faith,
heard that there
was something going on here
that was worth pursuing,
and came here.
And six months later, brought
his wife and their three
children, one of whom
was my grandfather.
JESSE HAINES: Amazing.
So, so powerful,
those crossroads.
So who is this book for?
Who do you hope reads this book?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Well, I
think we wanted to raise
awareness of the issue.
And we wanted to do it in
a way that didn't alienate.
I mean, right now there
are sides in immigration.
We didn't want to
alienate either side.
We really just wanted
to remind people
of what makes America great,
and that we're all immigrants.
And I think we've been able to
accomplish that because we're
telling the personal
story of success,
and it resonates with
everyone and with every group.
ANDREW TISCH: The book
is completely apolitical.
And we run the gamut from
Nancy Pelosi to Elaine Chao,
from Cory Booker to Tim Scott.
We have people on the left
and people on the right.
Immigration itself really
is not a political issue,
in most cases.
There are a few
people for whom it is.
There are Native Americans
who have been here,
and who have gotten
screwed, quite frankly.
There are people who came
over here unwillingly, i.e.
slaves.
But for the most part, this
is not a political book.
This is a book to
raise awareness that we
are a nation of immigrants.
America and Israel are
probably the only countries
in the world that have been
created by and for immigrants.
JESSE HAINES: Yes.
Yes.
It's not a political
book, but boy,
is immigration a hot
political topic right now.
So I want to kind of delve
into that a little bit.
What do you think--
has the direction of
the political discourse
around immigration--
are we moving forward?
Are we moving backwards?
It is a hot topic.
It is divisive.
What is our status as a
nation today, in terms of,
have we moved kind of backwards
or forwards in our ability
to talk about this
issue of immigration?
ANDREW TISCH: Well, we've
always been somewhat xenophobic
in this country.
Last year was the
100th anniversary
of the Immigration Act
of 1918, which was also
known as the Asiatic Barred
Act, which basically barred most
Asians from coming to America
because people in California
thought there were
too many Asians here.
And it was literally
impossible for an Asian woman
to get a visa to come
here because people wanted
the Asians that came here--
if they wanted to get
married-- to go back
to their native country
and get married, and not
stay in America.
So we we've always been
somewhat xenophobic.
We've always had negative
discourse about immigration.
When people first
started coming in,
when groups first
it's taken a generation
and generation and a half
for them to be accepted.
So it's not that this is
the first time that we've
had terrible xenophobia.
But what's going
on now is certainly
of great concern
to every one of us.
MARY SKAFIDAS: In
pulling together
the stories for the book,
we studied the waves
of immigration because
we wanted to make sure
that we had enough stories
that were representative
of each wave.
And you know, we quickly
came to the realization
that how we feel
about immigration
as a country is cyclical.
And we happen to
be in a down cycle,
but I think people realize
that the US absolutely
needs immigrants.
Right?
40% of Fortune 500 companies
were founded by immigrants,
or they were--
ANDREW TISCH: Or the
children of immigrants.
MARY SKAFIDAS: --the
So--
JESSE HAINES: Including Google.
ANDREW TISCH: Including Google.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Right.
Right.
So I think every
new group that comes
in, there's always this fear.
And it takes a while
to get over it.
But then there's the realization
that you need immigrants.
We need immigrants.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
Let's talk about that
a little bit more.
I mean, from your
standpoint, what
are some of the economic
arguments for immigration?
Because I think that
also fuels the fear
of things being taken away.
But there's a pretty
strong economic rationale
for why immigration is--
ANDREW TISCH:
Well, first of all,
let's just take something
as simple as unemployment.
We have basically
full employment
in the United States right now.
We have 3.1%, 3.2% unemployment.
That is full employment,
and anyone that wants a job
can probably get a job.
Maybe not the best job
in the world, but we
need more people to be working.
And we just don't
have enough people.
Now, we have, in this
country, achieved ZPG, also.
So if we want to change
the zero population growth,
that's going to take
about 20, 25 years.
And we don't have the social
systems to run that many more
people through the schools,
so that's impractical.
So we need immigrants.
We need immigrants to come in.
We also need immigrants because
we've got three Ponzi schemes
in Washington.
We've got Medicare, Medicaid,
and Social Security.
JESSE HAINES: Got it.
Got it.
ANDREW TISCH: And the
only way that they work
is if we get a broader and
broader population working
base to pay in, because
the three of them
are funded by
current dollars, not
by any kind of real trust fund.
It's a game the government has
played, and everybody knows it,
and nobody's doing
anything about it.
So we need immigration.
We need immigrants just
as workers, number one.
Number two, many immigrants take
jobs that nobody else will do.
And it's a plain and
simple fact of life
that immigrants want to come
here and they want to work,
and they want to
work hard, and they
want to do whatever it takes.
And oftentimes, they
end up with the jobs
that nobody else will take.
So that's very important.
And then you look at the
brains that stay here,
and the number of
PhDs that come here.
And you look at the
university systems.
We have the greatest
university system in the world.
Of the top 50 universities
in the world, 40 of them
are American universities
by the latest rankings.
Boy, if I was running the
country, any foreigner that
got a PhD, I'd immediately
confiscate their passport,
and pull their--
and say, you got a PhD here.
You got to work here
for X number of years.
Because to give them an
eviction notice is insanity.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
And I'm not asking where
you stand on these issues,
but why is immigration, at this
moment in time, so polarizing?
Why are we involved
in such heated debate
over the wall, the ban.
Given that it's hard
to argue with, I think,
what this book makes so
clear, we are all immigrants.
This country is founded
on values of openness
and embracing everyone from
gathering our huddled masses.
Why has the dialogue around
immigration gotten so heated?
ANDREW TISCH: Well let me let
me turn around and ask you,
what are we not polarized on
in this country right now?
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE HAINES: True.
True.
ANDREW TISCH: We are living
in a political environment
where everything
is being polarized.
And that gets into a broader
question of leadership,
but I think it's going to take a
while for the pendulum to swing
back to more cooperation.
A lot of the things
I'm doing in Washington
involve trying to reestablish
some sort of decorum
and ability to work
across the aisles.
JESSE HAINES: That's great.
That's great.
What changes would you make
in our current immigration
policy, were you to be able
to wave your magic wand?
ANDREW TISCH: You
want to start that?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Sure.
I think Andrew actually
outlined a number of them.
And obviously, we are not
immigration policy experts,
nor do we play
one on television.
And this is not a question that
we typically want to answer.
I mean, the focus of this was
really to raise awareness.
But I think the realization
that we need immigrants,
that we are pushing a
lot of the brain power
that we educate out
of the country--
should it be based on skill?
Should it be based on family
members bringing more family
members over?
I think those are
valid questions.
And if they could be done in a
way that wasn't so sensational
and just on social
media only, I think
these are valid questions
that we should ask ourselves,
and would help the
country move forward.
ANDREW TISCH: And things
like DACA-- that's insanity.
What are we going to do,
send people back to a country
that they've never been to?
It's insanity.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Google was
one of the companies that
was very outspoken about
the need for immigration,
and the importance of being
able to bring people here
from other countries to be
able to work for Google.
Have you guys talked
about this internally?
Does this come up in meetings?
JESSE HAINES: I mean, yes.
And we can get the
group involved in this.
Googlers are
opinionated and not shy.
A lot of the discourse goes
on, I think, face-to-face,
but also there's a
number of online places
where Google can discuss
and get into the issues.
I know that Sundar
has spoken out--
MARY SKAFIDAS: Very vocal, yeah.
JESSE HAINES: --on
immigration, and has personally
committed funds to
support certain issues.
And maybe there's
folks in the room
who can speak more to this.
I also read that Larry
and Sergey, our founders,
are also immigrants.
And I came across an
article that was critical,
actually, of Larry in
particular for being
quieter on immigration.
So I think Google demands
a lot of its leadership
when it comes to these issues.
MARY SKAFIDAS: But
I think companies
being vocal about this is going
to be one of the things that's
going to help turn the tide.
I mean, John Tish, who
heads up the Lowe's Hotels--
he's very outspoken about
this because of the need
for immigrants, especially when
you have a large hotel company
that you need to
staff seasonally.
And it's become
something that's been
very troublesome, especially
for the travel and tourism
industry.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
Have you seen other corporations
or business leaders sort
of really stepping out on
this topic in ways that have
been meaningful and impactful?
ANDREW TISCH: We're starting
to see more and more.
The Chamber of
Commerce is starting
to get more vocal about it.
And you're starting
to hear more people.
And I think as the
labor pool tightens up,
you'll hear more and more
senior executives, who
can't get the right
people, comment about it.
JESSE HAINES: Right.
So I want to give
the Googlers a chance
to start asking some questions.
So start thinking of your
questions, and we have mics.
But just getting
back to the stories,
I am curious what your
favorite one or ones are.
And I hope this isn't
like asking you to pick
your favorite child--
probably a little bit--
and why.
MARY SKAFIDAS: I have three.
JESSE HAINES: And maybe
you could tell the group--
MARY SKAFIDAS: I have three.
I have three because
I like a lot of them.
But I'm going to pick
three from people
you probably haven't heard of.
One is Eric Mezza.
There's a chapter
in the back that's
undocumented-- focuses on
undocumented immigrants,
and my aunt was one of them.
You know, she took
the job nobody wanted.
She worked in the
garment industry.
She matched collars to
jackets for pennies a collar.
But she saved a lot
of what she made,
and she was able to put me
and my cousin through college,
so we have no student
loans, which is
amazing on what she had made.
But there's two stories.
One is Juliana Perez.
She had DACA status.
She just graduated from
Georgetown Law School
and is now an
immigration lawyer.
When the book was published,
she had just passed her bar,
so she was very
excited about that.
And that is a tremendous story.
Then there's Eric Mezza who is a
junior in Harvard now, I think?
ANDREW TISCH: No, a senior.
MARY SKAFIDAS:
Senior in Harvard.
Brilliant, brilliant
mathematical mind.
But his parents were
migrant workers.
They would pick oranges in
Florida, then move to Michigan
and back.
And a nonprofit organization
kind of saw him,
saw his grades, and was able
to kind of pluck him out
of the crowd and help
him get to Harvard.
And then the last
one is Ahmed Ahmed.
I think he was born in
a Somali refugee camp.
He moved here when he was
about a couple of years old.
He ended up going to Cornell.
He's now in Oxford, right?
A Rhodes scholar.
And it's just the
thing that resonates
with me is, his parents had a
privileged life where he lived.
And his mother's now raising
her family basically in tents.
And when they moved
to the United States,
they had nothing.
But she views this as
the best day of her life
because they were able
to start fresh, and not
be worried about men
with machine guns
coming and taking their
family members away.
So those are the three for me.
ANDREW TISCH: I
think I'll pick out
two I'll pick Ryan Platt, who
is now a sophomore at Cornell.
And those are the
only two Cornell--
MARY SKAFIDAS: That's not true.
ANDREW TISCH: But Ryan is the
daughter of a single mother.
She's adopted from
a Chinese orphanage.
And when she went back to China
to see the orphanage from where
she came, she tells
the story about walking
into the orphanage
and seeing all
these little Chinese
babies, all girls.
And she said she had a
very tough time identifying
with them because
every time she looks
in the mirror in the morning,
she sees an American girl.
And it just stuck with me
that her identity is American.
And I guess the other one
is Stephanie Murphy, who
was a Vietnamese boat
person who left as a--
MARY SKAFIDAS: Which
you got to love
with a last name
like Murphy, right?
JESSE HAINES: I know, I'm like--
ANDREW TISCH: And
her family left
Vietnam when it was taken over.
And they got marooned
on the South China Sea.
The engine broke down,
and they were adrift,
and they got picked
up by the US Navy,
refuelled, fixed the engine,
pointed them towards Malaysia.
And Stephanie is, today, a
Congresswoman from Orlando.
So those are the
ones that I like.
I love Angela Buchwald, who's
a Korean-born rabbi at Central
Synagogue.
Cory Booker's essay is great.
Every one of them has
something in there
that people will
find interesting.
And some are more
interesting than others.
I love Pete Gogolak's Pete
Gogolak was a football player.
They came over from Hungary.
And he changed the
world twice, actually,
because he and his brother
couldn't figure out
how to kick a football.
They kicked it
sideways, not forward.
JESSE HAINES: Soccer-style.
ANDREW TISCH: And became the
first soccer-style kickers.
And then Pete was drafted by the
New York Giants and the Buffalo
Bills, and started kicking
for the Buffalo Bills.
And the New York
Giants hired him away
for a bonus of $90,000.
And the uproar was so great
that it led to the merger talks
between the American
Football League and the NFL.
So he changed the word twice.
The way we kick the football,
and the way we watch football.
JESSE HAINES: I love that story.
I love that story.
There are so many good ones.
OK.
Let's open up the
mics to questions.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Am I first?
JESSE HAINES: You are.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Bjorn.
I am from Denmark.
I have lived in this country
now for 20 years, this month.
And I also have a PhD.
You mentioned that.
I have that from this country.
And very much agree, by
the way, that instead
of trying to kick
us out afterwards,
you should try to keep us.
I managed to do that.
And I am looking at citizenship
in a couple of years.
I am also white--
very.
[LAUGHTER]
And I want to say--
and ask what you
think, obviously--
and I should also
say, politically, I'm
as left-leaning as
you get probably, OK?
In terms of immigration, at
least, and many more things.
But I don't actually
think it's very useful
to say that we are
all immigrants,
because if you go out in
Pennsylvania in a mining city,
or whatever they're called,
you will have people
who are white like me and
who have no identity of being
immigrants.
That is to say, no one who
is alive in that family
are actually immigrants.
No one's direct immigrants.
They didn't came here.
They didn't come here.
They were born here.
And so to someone
like them, especially
a lot of Trump voters, we
know, it is not the same
as saying, here's a Danish guy.
Let him come over, get
a PhD, learn a lot,
and then contribute
to this society.
That's not the same as
the kinds of immigrants
that we all know that Trump and
his followers are afraid of.
And so calling them all
immigrants I don't think
is useful.
What do you think?
ANDREW TISCH: OK.
My feeling is, we have
essays here from Mayo Stuntz.
Part of his family came
over as Hessian soldiers
in the Revolutionary
War, and that's
the young part of the family.
The older part of the
family came over along
about the Mayflower.
And they recognize that they
came from somewhere else.
Maybe they're not
immigrants this generation
or this past generation
But at some point,
everyone's going
to have to admit they came
over from somewhere else,
unless their last
name is Thundercloud.
And I think that that's
the reality of it.
Now if they don't want to
be reminded of it, fine.
I don't mind offending them,
if that's how they feel.
MARY SKAFIDAS: But I think
you make a good point, though,
because some would say
the stagnation in parts
of Pennsylvania is
what kind of tipped--
even though we have
a great economy,
and there's low
unemployment, there's
a lot of stagnant employment,
or no wage increases, which
has motivated a
lot of the country
to want to believe
what Trump was saying,
at least when the
election was going on.
And I read "Hillbilly Elegy."
I'm sure there are
a lot of people
that read it in this room,
which kind explained it to me.
But the point of
this wasn't to argue
with that particular person
who we may or may not
be able to change their
mind, but for there
to be an awareness that
their forefamily started
the same way.
The book is not going to
solve all the problems.
But I think as the
immigration debate goes,
this is one of the things
that has not been polarizing.
It has actually been unifying.
We need many more
things like that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
My name's Jenny Johnson.
And Andrew, I wanted to ask
you, since you're so involved
in New York City,
and New York City
is a city that has been
founded on immigrants,
do you see cities serving a
role in facilitating immigration
beyond the connection to
Washington and the government?
ANDREW TISCH: Absolutely.
I believe that,
first of all, cities
are where the immigrants
generally start out.
And the services that the
cities are going to provide
are going to be
very, very important.
My wife, Ann, who is
sitting right behind you,
is an educator and
has school in Astoria,
where they teach people from,
what, 67 different countries?
Who are immigrants from
67 different countries.
You don't get that
in too many places.
So I think the cities are the
places where the immigrants
tend to go to first.
And they have the social systems
that are there to help them.
And in the old days,
the social systems
were by the
immigrants themselves,
or by the descendants
of the immigrants.
So the Irish helped the Irish,
and the Jews helped the Jews,
and the Italians
helped the Italians.
MARY SKAFIDAS: And the
religious institutions.
ANDREW TISCH: And the religious
institutions were and are--
MARY SKAFIDAS: Very, yeah.
ANDREW TISCH: --very important.
So I think cities,
all municipalities,
we want to make it as easy
as possible for people
to come and become productive
members of society.
JESSE HAINES: Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: My name's
Hannah Bradheim.
I'm the granddaughter of
one of that people who
wrote in the book, and the
great granddaughter of one
of the people in the book.
JESSE HAINES: Wow.
AUDIENCE: So I'm Morris Turritz'
great granddaughter, who's
one of the people in the book.
So for me, it was great to
be able to read from the book
and see--
I knew my great grandfather's
last name was [? Turritz. ?]
I had not known his first name.
I knew he was from Lithuania.
I didn't know where in
Lithuania he was from.
So I was wondering, for the
people who worked on the book
and wrote in the book, how much
of it was a discovery for them,
for yourselves also
included parts in it?
Did you find a lot
of the people writing
different chapters learned
a lot of different things?
Were they sort of of interesting
or unusual things that came up?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Yeah.
We stopped writing the stories
ourselves because people
hadn't done their homework.
So when they had to write
the stories themselves,
they said they started
talking to family members
because someone always has
the aunt or the uncle that
has kept track of
everything in a notebook.
They started to do some
research on their own.
They discovered things.
The family always believed
this, but then this was true.
And I think it was
engaging for them.
They were energized by it.
Every couple of weeks, they
would say, oh, we found this.
Can we add this?
Is it too late?
I think there were very
few people that we asked
that actually turned us down.
And a number of them were
either writing their own book,
or had completely lost
touch with history,
to the gentleman's point that he
was saying before you, just had
forgotten their family history.
But I think of the
majority of the people
that we had asked
were so energized
to be able to
participate in this,
and really kind of used
this as a research project
for their own lineage.
ANDREW TISCH: I'll
tell you my story.
Our family lore was that we
came from [? Dniprovska ?]
in the Ukraine.
And everybody thought that
in 1904, the entire family
went to Odessa.
And half the family turned
left and went to Tashkent,
and the other half of the family
turned right and came here.
And so when I was
doing the research,
I went to Ellis Island, and
they found the ship's manifest
that had my grandfather's
name on it in March of 1904,
and the ship was from Hamburg.
Now, there was no way you could
go from Odessa to Hamburg.
You really had to go, if you
were going from Dniprovska,
directly to Hamburg.
So they probably took
a train to Hamburg.
And we surmised that
there was some feeling
that they were in peril because
of recent pogroms in Russia.
But the family went to Hamburg.
My great grandfather
came over here in March.
And then six months later,
my great grandmother
and her three children, one
of whom was my grandfather,
came over to join my
grandfather after he scouted out
and found a place
for them to live.
So the whole idea that half
the family went to Tashkent
after we all went to Odessa
kind of went out the window.
But doing the research
was a lot of fun,
and it connected me with
a couple of relatives who
still remember what's going on.
I am now pretty much in
touch with some of them
pretty regularly.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Did
you love reading
about your family's history?
Was there a lot--
I mean, you didn't even know
your grandfather's first name,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It was fun.
Every once in a while,
members of my family
have the same
Facebook post they do,
because my great grandfather
had [INAUDIBLE] business,
and [INAUDIBLE] granite.
So that was the sum
total of what I knew.
My grandfather, Joseph
Boward-- he found a bunch more
information in there.
And then recent, I
was in his basement,
and I found a bunch more
information about other things
that I think he probably
dug out recently,
and that's why they were on top.
ANDREW TISCH: And
your grandfather
was a professor of mine
in business school.
JESSE HAINES: Wow.
That's cool.
Other questions?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Good afternoon, Andrew and Mary.
Thank you for being
here this afternoon.
So some of the more
sensational stories
that have animated new
activism amongst Googlers
and young people everywhere,
and really just almost
any citizen--
border separations, the wall,
immigration bands, et cetera--
they bring to mind
this question of, what
can we be doing, as
people of some privilege,
to give our leaders a little
bit more courage to address
the systemic issues that
underlie these outcomes
that we've seen in recent news?
What is your advice on
addressing those people,
or participating as a
citizen, not just an observer?
ANDREW TISCH: I'm a big
one for political activism.
I would just say, vote.
Most important thing
you can do is vote.
Even if you think your vote
doesn't count, it counts.
People read it.
And I don't think
I've missed voting
since I was 21 years old.
I even vote by
absentee ballot, just
to make sure that I'm
not going to miss it.
But then, I've gotten
involved politically
in initiatives that I
find very important.
One of the initiatives
I'm involved in
is the US Global
Leadership Coalition,
which its sole purpose
is to keep foreign aid
in the federal budget.
Foreign aid being 6/10 of
1% of the federal budget.
But there's always some
idiot congressman who says,
if we can just
cut out government
waste and foreign aid, then
we can balance the budget.
Forget that we're
running a trillion dollar
deficit this year, and every
year as far as we can see.
But get involved
and express yourself
because there's a
lot of things that
have to be done to get this
country, in my opinion,
moving in the right direction.
This country's--
MARY SKAFIDAS: I want to test
Andrew's memory for a second.
And he's known for [INAUDIBLE]
for not forgetting anything.
You know, 50 years ago,
we signed this contract
and that's what the
contract will say.
But when he was in Monticello
giving the commencement
address, you had top
10 things that people
should do to get
involved that they loved.
One of them was vote,
friends with your neighbor--
ANDREW TISCH: Make friends
with your neighbor.
Visit America's sites.
Go see the Statue of Liberty,
and the Liberty Bell,
and the Grand Canyon.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Yes, activism.
ANDREW TISCH: The big
thing is get involved.
MARY SKAFIDAS: How
much of us actually
spend times being American, and
celebrating America, and going
to the Grand Canyon, or making
friends with our neighbors,
or getting involved locally?
Even if it won't give us any
grandeur on social media.
And there were 10 things that
were really well received
by the new citizens, and
the existing citizens,
in the swearing-in ceremony.
ANDREW TISCH: One of
the things, if you ever
have the opportunity
to do it, go
visit a swearing-in ceremony.
Go attend a swearing-in
ceremony where
you get to meet new
citizens, and find out
how important being an
American is to them.
MARY SKAFIDAS: If we could make
that a requirement for elected
officials, we would be having
a different conversation.
JESSE HAINES: Is that something
that you need to get invited?
How does one do that?
ANDREW TISCH: We
have to find a way.
JESSE HAINES: So you
can't just show up.
You can't just--
ANDREW TISCH: You can.
A lot of them--
JESSE HAINES: --invite yourself.
ANDREW TISCH:
Monticello, on July 4th
they have a swearing-in.
I was fortunate
enough, Mary and I
were asked to be in attendance.
And I gave a keynote address.
MARY SKAFIDAS: That
one you can show up to.
It's huge.
JESSE HAINES: OK.
ANDREW TISCH: There were
67 new immigrants who
were sworn in as new citizens.
And there were, what--
MARY SKAFIDAS: 3,000.
ANDREW TISCH: --3,000
people were there?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Yeah.
It's hot.
Bring an umbrella.
But it was a
wonderful experience.
And like Andrew
was saying, if this
was a requirement for
elected officials,
it would help change
the conversation.
I think he's right.
AUDIENCE: Someone
asked a question
about New York City and state
having many social programs
to help immigrants, and also
you can get free legal advice,
and so on.
And I was actually
wondering, is it
all in New York City and
state who's doing it?
Or were more states
in the United States
who are also involved in
doing programs like that?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Well, just
from the stories in the book,
Ahmed Ahmed--
his family was sent to Michigan.
And they had built-in programs.
I don't know if it was provided
by the city or the state.
It could have been a
nonprofit organization.
But they helped them
find an apartment.
They helped his
parents find a job.
They helped them
register for school.
I think more urban settings
are probably easier,
but there is Columbus,
Ohio, for instance.
Actually, their mayor says,
we are open to immigrants
because they need them.
They have plants there that
they can't find enough employees
for, so he was covered
in New York Magazine,
just maybe a year
ago, for setting up
this very pro-immigrant
city that attracted.
And he actually
would raise his hand
and say, yes, I would like how
ever many new immigrants are
coming over this month.
And they worked at
the sausage factory.
There were different other
factories and plants there.
But it's one of the
things that helped
their economy recover faster
than other parts of Ohio.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Yeah.
My cousin, actually,
is an American citizen.
He lived for Greece
for a number of years.
He's a mechanical engineer
and he just moved back here
a year ago.
And there were great
systems in place.
He's a citizen, but his
wife and his son aren't.
There are great
systems in place,
free of charge in New York,
that helped him kind of settle
his family and assimilate.
And the amazing thing is--
he's a mechanical engineer--
so within three weeks,
he had three job offers.
AUDIENCE: Are your
stories in this book?
And how did they influence the
way you approached this book?
MARY SKAFIDAS: Well, his
story started it all.
It was the research.
Go ahead.
ANDREW TISCH: Yes.
Yes, indeed, our
stories are in the book.
And when we send out
the request to people,
we led with our chins in that
we sent our stories to them
to say, we're willing to
put our stories in the book.
We hope that you will join us.
And we had very few turndowns
from people because they were
excited to be part of this.
And one of the things
you'll find in the book
is that the last
eight pages are blank.
And they're just lined
so that you can write
your story into your book.
We also give you the
opportunity to go
to
www.journeysanamericanstory.com,
and put your story
onto our website,
so that there are
additional stories
on the website of people
whose stories came in too
late to make publication.
So we're anxious that
people tell the stories
because the more
they talk about it,
the more we believe
people will remember
that we are all, as Americans,
from somewhere else.
But we're here as Americans,
and we're here together
JESSE HAINES: I think that's
a really great note to end on.
Thank you again for being here.
Thank you for creating this
book, for sharing your stories,
for sharing the stories
of so many others.
And I hope you guys will
share your stories, maybe
by hand, maybe on the website.
And thank you for
being here today.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Thank you.
ANDREW TISCH: Thank
you very much.
MARY SKAFIDAS: Thank you.